welcome to the Matt Walsh show everybody
remember to subscribe subscribe
subscribe so uh subscribe on iTunes to
get the whole the whole show or you can
become a premium member of The Daily
wire I hope you're all surviving the
polar vortex as it's being dramatically
called it's not that bad where I live or
maybe at about 25 degrees or so so
pretty balmy temperatures we did get a
bit of snow though so you know I enjoy
taking the kids out last night to go
sledding and of course when I say I take
them out to go sledding what I mean is
that I'm the one who does most of the
sledding while they're making snow
angels or whatever they're doing I'm on
the you know I'm hitting the slopes with
that with a little plastic green saucer
thing so as a lot of fun yesterday I
wrote about the student loan crisis and
I talked about this on the show a couple
days ago I think and the case that I
made is that just a review very very
briefly to get into what I want to talk
about what I said and I've made this
case many times is that on an individual
level the way to deal with the absurd
cost of of college is to or one way to
deal with it is to maybe not go to
college you know often when you notice
that something is absurdly crazy
expensive and you're thinking about what
water ways to deal with how expensive
this thing is well one of the things
that you could do is just not buy that
thing right now I'm not defending
colleges that charge so much I've been
accused of that of course I'm not there
I agree with everyone who says that it's
ridiculous that universities charge so
much that require students to mortgage
the next fifteen years of their life
just for the privilege of a debt
attending classes I agree that it's
immoral to lend tens of thousands of
dollars to a person who has no job and
no assets and no wealth a net worth of
zero and no immediate prospects of
making an income of any kind
what's worse many of these kids are
purchasing this massively expensive
thing without having any idea as to how
they might actually use it or if they
might use it so it's like selling a
Cessna you know a plane to a broke 17
year old who doesn't even have a pilot's
license and really
has known no immediate plans of even
getting one so the whole system is
ludicrous and unethical and in too many
ways to count but what frustrates me is
that when we have this conversation what
frustrates me it's not just the victim
mentality of the college grads who did
after all sign on the dotted line and
agree to the terms of the loan even if
it is a you know a loan that they never
should have taken out in the first place
so it's not just the victim mentality
yeah that's one thing that annoys me but
even more so it's the way that this
conversation like so many other
conversations in our culture today
avoids the one clear solution most
people are just unwilling to consider or
take seriously the one single thing that
could actually address and finally solve
the student loan crisis everyone wants
to talk about policies they want to talk
about regulations and laws and
everything none of that's gonna do
anything in fact it would probably make
the problem much worse
the real answer is obvious it's what I
already said it's for fewer people to go
to college universities have no
incentive to drive down the cost of
their tuition if everybody's gonna keep
going regardless I made I made the
analogy in my piece yesterday where I
talked about imagine that you're a denim
company selling jeans and imagine that
you've discovered that everybody will
buy your jeans no matter how much they
cost you raise the cost to 90 bucks
everyone's still buying them in fact
more people are buying them you raise
them to the 300 people are still buying
them so so what are you gonna do are you
are you gonna drop down the prices back
down to 30 bucks just to be nice or are
you gonna keep raising those prices
because people are willing to buy it
well if maybe if you're a really nice
person or a terrible businessman or both
you'll drop the prices just for the heck
of it just to be nice but if you are
focused on the bottom line then you know
you're gonna have if people want to
mortgage their homes to buy a pair of
pants then you're gonna be perfectly
willing and happy to have to have them
do that if it puts money in your pockets
and that's how colleges operate so if
you're thinking that colleges are run by
really nice generous
you know philanthropists they're not
they're run by business people who want
to make money that's what it's about
College will become less expensive the
moment that a preponderance of potential
students start showing a willingness to
not go it starts showing a little bit of
prudence and discernment I'm not saying
that everybody should avoid college
because the prices are so high if you
want to be an architect or an engineer
or or you know a doctor or a lawyer or
something then obviously in those cases
the cost of college even as high as it
is might be worth it but if you know
that you want to get into a line of a
line of work where the degree isn't
necessary then obviously you shouldn't
go and most importantly if you have no
idea what you want to do with your life
if you have no clue what your skills are
your passions your interests if you have
no real five or ten year plan at all at
this point then the last thing you
should do is is is is sign up for this
massive loan to buy a thing that you
aren't even sure if you're going to use
and even if you do use it you don't at
this point know how you're going to use
it in no other situation would we ever
recommend that somebody buy something
for $100,000 without knowing whether or
not they're even going to use it we
would never say yeah you know just go
buy the thing for six figures and then
you know at some point you figure out
what to do with it we would never say
that in any other situation we should
stop saying with a college education it
is absurd so that's my whole case I
think it's a it's a really reasonable
case it's just if you know that you're
going to use this education and that
ultimately it will pay off financially
then go do it if you don't know that yet
then don't go to college right now that
doesn't mean NEVER ago it just means
don't go right now until you figured it
out really reasonable point of view I
think and this is a I don't know why I
just did this with it I'm doing the
Donald Trump I'm developing Donald
Trump's hand mannerisms for some reason
I think it's a really reasonable point
of view just don't buy an expensive
thing unless you know how you're going
to use it that's my whole case very
logical I think but I've heard from a
lot of people who said
well that's not fair you know College
shouldn't be this expensive in the first
place yeah I know that I'll Drive myself
into debt going to college and it's true
that I don't know what I want to do with
my life and all of that but I should be
able to go to college I should be able
to college should be affordable for me I
should be able to go just for the
experience and just for the education
even if I'm never going to use it in any
practical way at all that's how it
should be this is what I'm hearing from
people and okay yeah maybe it should be
but it's not though see that's it should
be okay fine but it's not it's not
that's not what it is should be fine not
though
so when you say should you're talking
about a world that doesn't exist you're
talking about a fantasy well you may as
well say you know what there should be
unicorns and the government should
assign flying unicorns to every person
every person should get their own flying
unicorns and the unicorn should be able
to make pancakes in the morning so I
should be able to get up in the morning
in the end there's a unicorn making me
pancakes that's how it should be and you
know what maybe it should be that way I
think that would be great but it's not
that way though so don't live your life
as though you have a flying unicorn that
makes pancakes because you don't and I
know you might say well you know having
affordable college is a more practical
should than flying unicorns fine but the
point is they are similar right now in
the fact that they are both situations
that don't exist maybe one is achievable
down the line but that's not the
situation right now for you so I heard
the same kind of thing yesterday when I
was and I don't remember exactly how
this came up but on Twitter we were
talking about the whole College thing
and the challenges that young people
face and I was making my case for hey
you know go get a job or live on your
own for a bit if you don't know what you
want to do with your life rather than
you you know rather than signing up for
this loan and go pay and go
to pay to do this really expensive thing
instead you could spend that time of
discernment working a job and making
money and living on your own gaining
life experience actual valuable life
experience because the life experience
you get in college I know you say well
college is an experience but the life
experience you get there is basically I
know it's easy for me to say because I
didn't go but it strikes me that it's
basically worthless it's not you know
the the day-to-day experience of being
in college you're not ever going to have
anything like that again
which means fine you'll have great
memories great but it's not going to
give you skills and and habits that will
do you much good anywhere else in life
now you live in an apartment by yourself
you learn to pay the bills you learn to
deal with landlords and everything
well--that's knows our skills and
talents that you're gonna take with you
for your whole life but whatever skill
you develop with living with a roommate
in the dorm partying and stuff I mean
yeah I know it's fun and memories are
great but I don't know if you should
drive yourself into six figures of debt
to make memories at this point of your
life or ever really actually so rather
than that you could go and get the life
experience it and and and make some
money and develop skills build your
resume while you're discerning and
figuring out what you want to do and so
I you know I was saying that and a bunch
of people said to me well well you know
I'd love to but there are no jobs around
where I live there are no jobs or living
expenses are very high you know what am
I supposed to do there's there's nowhere
to work and I can't I can't live
anywhere because it's it's so expensive
I'm living on my parents house and so I
said well then move move to a different
place it's a big country there are lots
of places that you could potentially
live so just move to a place with low
cost of living and more job
opportunities those places do exist
there are a lot of places like that and
it's a really exciting thing because
America is like I don't know it's it's
it's millions of square miles of
land and you could go anywhere you go
literally anywhere you want so go
somewhere else but once again I got the
same kind of response people saying well
that's not fair that that's that's
that's that's not how it should be it
shouldn't be that way
I shouldn't have to move I shouldn't
have to move I should be able to stay
where I am I've got my family here my
whole life and my friends and this is
where I grew up and and this is the or
the town that I live in it
I shouldn't have to move I want to be
close to family I should be able to be
close to family people should be able to
stay where they are that's the way it
should be there's a problem in society
when everyone has to leave and dispersed
and Families are broken up this isn't
how society should be I agree but that
is how society is okay it shouldn't be
but it is so that's all it just is this
is something I noticed with Millennials
a lot okay and I'm not generally a
millennial basher I am a millennial
myself and as I've said many times in
the past our generation did get screwed
by previous generations there there's no
question about that the baby boomers
drove this country into bankruptcy they
ruined most of our institutions they
left the institution of marriage and
tatters and look what they did with
government media and academia and
everything the baby boomer generation is
a generation of generally speaking not
for all of them but generally speaking
as a generation of selfishness and
financial irresponsibility and and they
are in general leaving the country in
worse shape than they found it which is
the ultimate indictment on any
generation it's you know how did it look
when you got it and how does it look now
and the baby boomers inherited a pretty
good situation a pretty prosperous
situation and that's not the situation
they're leaving behind so they have
little room to criticize anyone and I'll
be the first to say that but that said
there are some legitimate criticisms of
the Millennial Generation and this is
one of them the refusal to deal with
reality
a refusal to acknowledge how things are
this insistence always on saying but it
shouldn't be it shouldn't be college
shouldn't be so expensive living
shouldn't be so expensive I shouldn't
have to move it shouldn't be this way
but it is and and you do have to deal
with it and that's just all there is to
it I'm afraid right now you know people
don't like my plan for dealing with
student debt because they say that we
need policy changes and everything else
okay even if I agreed with that and I
don't really but even if I did that
doesn't change the immediate situation
and I'd rather talk about what can a
person do right now in this exact moment
an individual person who is looking at
the situation as it currently stands
what can they do I mean should they be
lobbying Congress is that is that the
way that they should that they should
personally be dealing with the situation
know you so that's that's the thing with
a lot of people my generation I've
noticed is just an absolute refusal to
simply deal with things and cope with
things as they are and so you end up
with a lot of Millennials who just stay
at home or they stay in their hometown
they whine and they complain and they
just tread water and run in place and do
nothing while whining about how things
should be well that's not how you change
things and if you notice that the that
the environment and the you know society
and everything around you it's not how
you want it to be
well you can't immediately do anything
about that but but you can do something
immediately about your own situation
that's the thing that you can
immediately grab a hold of and change so
do that and then there's just this
general resistance people in my
generation have often - moving to a
different town to pursue opportunities I
don't understand I can't wrap my head
around that do you expect the
opportunities to just come to you what's
what's the plan exactly to sit there
pouting until the situation improves
well it's never going to
proof so you're just gonna be pouting
for the rest of your life and you're
gonna be a loser who does nothing and
accomplishes nothing in life if that's
how you go about it there are no jobs
okay
yes there are but you just have to go
somewhere else for them I do not
understand a 20 year old or 22 year old
person say there are no jobs anyway
there are so many jobs everywhere but
you you just have to be willing to go
more than like 20 miles from where you
grew up
that's all I mean go work in North
Dakota as a go work on an oil rig in
North Dakota make six figures and live
in a place where the living expenses are
almost like non-existent and just bank
money you know what I wish I had done
that you know what I wish I had done
when I was 18 I wish I had gone in North
Dakota and worked for seven years on an
oil rig and just saved tons of money and
written and that's you know what that's
what I think if you're 18 years old go
do that go work on a little rig for
about five six seven years and then and
then do it to what you'd go to college
you could pay for it all on your own you
pay for it out of pocket or something I
mean there are so many different things
you can do that and especially when
you're young and you don't have kids now
when you have kids and you have a family
the situation becomes a little bit more
complicated although even then look I've
moved since I was since I moved at the
house when I was 20 and including that
move I've moved five times in the last
12 years and three of those times when I
had kids it's a lot harder when you have
kids and I've changed jobs I've changed
careers I mean I you know I when I it
was only six seven months after we had
our twins and we were living eight eight
hours away from family and we were
living in Kentucky
eight hours away from family we were
completely you know alone and and we had
just had kid twins so now all the sudden
we went from a two-person family to a
four-person family and it was only six
seven months after that when we made the
decision which was probably an insane
decision but I was gonna leave
full-time employment and I was going to
go full-time on run blogging I had just
started my website and I was just
writing I was just writing and we
decided I was gonna do that full-time
and it was a crazy risk to take it could
have been backfired horribly and and
completely ruined us but it was a risk
we felt like we should make and in the
end it paid off but so the point is I'm
not just saying this you know I've been
through that myself I've taken the risks
I've had you know and I know that moving
is hard the first couple times I moved I
had no money and so you know you're
you've got very little money it's like
you can't even rent a u-haul hardly when
you get to a place you've got you've got
to put a down payment on our apartment
and all that and so if you've saved
money then maybe you have enough to get
the u-haul and to put the downpayment
but then you're gonna have no money and
so you better be able to get a job and
then you know you're kind of climbing
out of that hole it's it's a difficult
thing to do
but it can be done and so sometimes you
have to do difficult things and my point
is when you have no kids and no family
it's like the you could do anything you
could go anywhere and worst case
scenario if the you know the worst thing
happens and you're and you end up on the
street like you have no money and even
that is you could deal with it there are
people who have lived in their cars but
until they were able to get enough money
to get an apartment I'm not saying you
want to end up with that but I'm saying
when you have no kids there's really
it's that is not disastrous with kids
that's disastrous without them so what
okay so that's what you do or you so you
couch surfer you know whatever you stay
in a motel or something I mean that's
what I did the message I'm always trying
to communicate to people especially
younger people without kids like you can
go and do anything you I know that
there's this there's this path that's
been set out for you and that everyone
you know there's this idea of what
you're supposed to do ABC you know
follow along the points on the path
because that's what everyone else does
but you don't really have to follow that
path and in fact that path for most
people is not the best one there are
better ways to go about
there are smarter ways for instance you
don't have to tip even if you decide you
want to go to college that doesn't have
to involve massive debt if you're
willing to just wait for a few years and
like I said work somewhere for a while
and if you're willing to do a job that's
a little bit more hands-on it's not a
cushy office job it might be a you know
a little bit more difficult physically
challenging it's not a job that you can
you know brag about on social media
maybe it won't be you know it won't be
the nice job that maybe some of your
friends are able to get maybe out of
college although a lot of them won't be
getting nice jobs either so but if
you're willing to do that for a few
years and then at that point if you
decide you want to go to college well
then you don't even have to send
yourself into debt because you'll have
the money to pay for it all right
that's a my life advice now let's we're
talking about life advice let's go to
the culture of death New York of course
passed that law last week outlawing or
should say allowing which it was
outlawed allowing abortion up until
birth we talked about that but now this
has kind of got the ball rolling for the
Democrats so Democrats in Virginia have
proposed a bill that would allow
abortions
up until seconds before birth Virginia
delegate Cathy Tron presented the bill
in a subcommittee this week and she was
questioned by chairman Todd Gilbert
about what this law actually involves
and it's pretty chilling to listen to so
so here's how that questioning way so
how late in the third trimester would
you be able to do that you know I'm it's
very unfortunate that our there are
physicians witnesses were not able to
attend today to speak specifically I'm
talking about your bill how late how
late in the third trimester could a
physician perform an abortion if he
indicated it would impair the mental
health of the of the woman or physical
health okay okay I'm talking about the
mental health so I mean through
the third trimester the third trimester
goes all the way up to 40 weeks okay but
to the end of the third trimester I
don't think we have the limit in the
bill so where it's obvious that a woman
is about to give birth she has physical
signs of that she is about to give a
birth would that still be a point at
which she could request an abortion if
she was so certified she's dilating mr.
chairman that would be a you know a
decision that the doctor the physician
and the women I understand that I'm
asking if your bill allows that my bill
would allow that yes so very disturbing
a baby that is mere minutes away from
birth a fully healthy viable baby can be
aborted at the behest of a fully
physically healthy woman moments before
birth if she feels that her mental
health would be harmed by the birth of
her child meanwhile you have Democrats
in Rhode Island who are working on a
similar bill except theirs would theirs
would allow abortion up until birth so
same as New York same as Virginia but it
would also repeal the partial birth
abortion ban in the state okay now
partial birth abortion is a is banned on
the federal level so even by overturning
the banned in Rhode Island that doesn't
mean that they're actually going to be
able to perform partial birth abortions
legally but this just shows you the fact
that the Democrats want to do that
tells you everything you need to know
about them do you know what you know
what partial birth abortion is okay I'll
tell you what it entails and this is
graphic so if you have kids in the car
maybe or if you have kids you know while
you're watching the solicitor's maybe
shut it off but a partial birth abortion
is when a fully viable fully healthy
baby who could survive outside of the
womb who has reached term is delivered a
and then moments before fully emerging
from the birth canal with with half of
its body hanging out of the birth canal
the baby's head is held inside the
woman's body and then his brain is
sucked out of his head that's what a
partial birth abortion is obviously no
difference at all
none between just delivering the baby
and killing him
this is infanticide and they're trying
to get around the infanticide by just
keeping one part of the body inside of
the mother again
that's banned on the federal level and
now Democrats I'm sure they would love
to overturn that federal ban they don't
they don't they can't right now but this
is where Democrats are these are
bloodthirsty evil lunatics who support
this kind of thing and it just goes to
show the Democrat Party is becoming more
and more radical especially on the
abortion issue they are you know they're
not moderating their stands or going to
the middle or anything like that which
is why in opposing them we have to be
just as radical on the other end of the
spectrum on the good end of the spectrum
on the spectrum on the on the on the
life preserving and loving and
protecting end of the spectrum because
Democrats are saying what we want all
abortions partial-birth everything
abortion for any reason at any point up
to and even after birth because partial
birth I mean that's the the birth has
happened at that point so that is really
an afterbirth abortion so that's what
Democrats are saying that's what
liberals want and our response has to be
no abortions none for anyone ever for
any reason life begins at conception
because if you try to moderate you try
to meet him in the middle they clearly
are not willing to do that and all
they're going to do is they're going to
keep
dragging you further and further and
closer to them they're gonna keep saying
okay yeah sure let's let's meet in the
middle just come a little bit closer to
us
yeah come a little bit come come closer
yeah no no I don't know just walk a
little bit further our way what we'll
meet you just keep coming but they never
do and that's how the that's how the
left has dragged the entire culture
further left because the left keeps
going more and more left while kind of
beckoning everyone else come you know
come meet us let's let's let's let's you
know let's let's compromise let's find a
middle ground but they keep going left
so at the middle ground the middle
ground is always shifting I realize I'm
saying left but I'm pointing right but
you know one of the thing about this I
was thinking about it is you know Kermit
Gosnell is is in prison for the rest of
his life for killing babies after they
were born and for you know other things
while putting putting women's yogi
killed at least one woman and put
unsanitary disgusting conditions of his
of his clinic and all that but the main
thing is that he killed babies probably
hundreds of babies after they were
already born but as I said there's no
difference between that there's no
biological no moral no physical
difference between that and killing a
baby moments before birth or even during
the process of birth so really I guess
we should just let Kermit Gosnell out of
prison III think we shouldn't allow
Democrats to kind of draw this
distinction between Kermit Gosnell and
so-called regular or good abortionist
there is notice there is no distinction
Kermit Gosnell was just an abortionist
he's no different from the rest of them
they're all the same now I would love
for all of them to be in prison I think
that's where they all belong but I don't
think we should let the left to draw
these distinctions and say no not not
Kermit Gosnell no he's totally that he's
not different so really if the laws were
consistent in Kermit Gosnell
should have maybe been fined for you
know disposing of medical waste
inappropriately so maybe give them a
$500 fine or something like that but
other than that it's all the same
there's no difference all right finally
we'll go to the inbox check some of your
messages and emails remember Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com Matt while show at
gmail.com if you have a question comment
concern hate mail anything that you that
you have this is from Ellie she says hi
Matt I'm a homeschooled ninth grade
student and I am involved in a wonderful
Christian co-op that I attend to once a
week since first grade I've been in a
cycle of learning about ancient history
for one year medieval history the next
year American history the third year the
cycle still repeats to this day and I
really enjoy it
and I feel that I'm getting a really
thorough education I've heard from my
friends and a few my family members that
the ancient and medieval courses are
pointless and learning about Charlemagne
is a waste of time
how would you defend the study of
ancient and medieval history if at all
thank you for the show I really enjoy it
well hi Ellie first of all it's awesome
that you enjoy learning about history
that's a great passion and interest to
have and I think you should cultivate it
I have the same interest myself being a
history nerd is one of the coolest
things you can be now I'm not quite
history nerd you might you might be I'm
see I aspire to be a history nerd that's
kind of that's a level up there
there are basically three levels there's
a history enthusiast and then you
graduate to history nerd and then you
become history buff so I'm still on the
enthusiast level hoping to make it to
nerd and then eventually buff that's
where I'm going you may be further along
than I am already but I think it's a
great thing as far as learning about the
Middle Ages that's one of the most
important and interesting times to learn
about there's this a lot of people think
that nothing happened and it's sort of
this time in history where humanity was
at a standstill and so we could just cut
that out and forget about it but that's
not the case at all I mean Charlemagne
is considered the father of Europe there
are a lot of other really interesting
important fascinating people Thomas
Aquinas and
and William Wallace and Joan of Arc and
da Vinci who was kind of more
Renaissance but still I think Leif
Eriksson who's you know a Viking made it
to North America 500 years before
Columbus and then think about all the
innovations that came out of the Middle
Ages like one of the most important ever
the printing press and the mechanical
clock and gunpowder and eyeglasses so
the next time someone tells you that
it's a waste of time to learn about
history and to learn about the Middle
Ages then ask them if they think the
printing press was a waste of time
because if it wasn't then obviously it's
not a waste of time to learn about it so
I would encourage you to keep doing that
this is from Johnny says hey Matt I
really liked your show especially the
ones you talked about theological and
philosophical ideas I was wondering
about what you think the stance of a
Christian should be towards meditation
because it is inspired by and is
advocated by non-christian new-agey and
even anti-christian like Sam Harris
thought should Christians avoid
meditation thanks in advance I think it
depends on the purpose and method of
meditation I think meditation that is
meant to sort of empty the mind
completely is problematic as Christians
we know that our minds should be focused
on God all the time not nothingness not
emptiness but contemplative prayer might
be confused with meditation and it's
similar in some ways but in that and it
could look like a very similar thing in
that it's very quiet very still sort of
thing but in that case you are centering
your thoughts and your mind on God so as
I understand it with the new agey type
of meditation it's all about just kind
of obliterating the ego and thinking
about nothing and just sort of being
there which i think is a problem but in
this case a contemplative prayer it's
about yeah you're not thinking about
yourself anymore you're trying to get
your thoughts away from yourself and
focus them up on God rather than just
dispersing your thoughts into the ether
you're trying to target them up and
focus on something good and holy so I
think that's a good thing
from Louisa says hi there Matt you
should be proud to know that a 36 year
old Spaniard thinks your show is pretty
great even though I don't live in
America almost everything you talk about
ends up being relevant to me the
problems we face as conservatives in
Europe are not that different from the
ones that you face in America for
example the Spanish government has been
pretending we don't have an immigration
problem for years now the poisonous
feminist ideology has also led to the
destruction of the nuclear family in
this country and consequently to a
dramatic increase in crime rates and
people living off welfare benefits moral
relativism has taken the place of
Christian values that are now dismissed
as old-fashioned and even oppressive the
pro-choice and the LGBTQ why WTF agendas
are inseparable and indistinguishable
from the liberal left's and they have
completely reshaped our society and even
infiltrated our public school system
politicians here have been just as
baffled about the fact that the
so-called far right is getting foothold
everywhere in Europe as they were about
Trump winning the elections in America
still it seems that Europe hasn't had
enough of the leftist nonsense just yet
that is just to name a few
anyway I've been listening to your
podcast from day one and I love it I
would appreciate if you gave a shout out
to me in one of your shows you have at
least one subscriber in Spain who cares
enough to say hi god bless well here's
your shoutout Luisa and please keep
fighting the fight over there in Spain I
know that you know on the on the on the
on the train into insanity and
destruction we're all on the same track
but I think you guys in Europe you're
just a few you're a few train cars ahead
of us so we can look over and see what's
happening to you and we know where we're
gonna be in just a few years from Luke
he says Matt one question what are your
favourite Civil War generals well Luke
I'll give you the best in order starting
at five five will be shared in four will
be Nathan Bedford Forrest three would be
grant two will be robert e lee and
number one would be Stonewall Jackson
and I think you could you could mix
around two through five you can mix and
match and move around the order but
number one I feel very strongly has to
be Stonewall Jackson I think he did
things that no one else could do in the
war or maybe in any war in American
history and he did it with this ragtag
Shoeless farm boys you look at just his
Valley campaign alone where he
maneuvered this small force all over the
Shenandoah Valley Valley marching dozens
of miles in a single day
and methodically picking apart these
larger armies winning battle after
battle it's just a thing of beauty and
just he was a you know fascinating
person and a great military commander
let's see I'll do one more from Joel he
says hi Matt I thought it was extremely
irresponsible to encourage people not to
go to college often I find your show and
you as a person to be hard to stomach
and insufferable but this was the last
straw for me I won't be listening or
following anymore
I think your anti-education stance is
idiotic at irresponsible even for you
yes you got lucky and got to be a
blogger for a living which I'm sure is a
fun and easy life but the rest of us
have real jobs and so we need an
education now that I mention it why
should anyone listen to you now that
you've admitted you have no education
well hello Joel I first of all you don't
have to listen to me
I give you my blessing to leave I just
ask that before you leave Joel please
just think of the good times we shared
don't focus on the bad don't focus on
the way things ended for us just think
of the good times that's all I ask
as far as my lack of education well I
have made the effort to to learn things
on my own which you can do there are
things called books I've got a few back
there and and so here's the here's the
interesting thing that I discover you
get is you could pick up a book right
and the book has what's called
information inside it and it's written
on its there's these things called words
on this thing called a page right and
then the words are assembled in such a
way as to communicate information and so
what you can do without paying anyone
$80,000 is you could just pick up the
book and read it and find out the
information it's a really fascinating
process you should look into so I was
able to do that but if you feel that a
person cannot really know anything
unless they've paid eighty thousand
dollars to walk in the doors of a
building that has the word school
written on it then
again you have every right to just just
ignore me as far as me being an
insufferable idiot that is a point that
I will not dispute but thanks for
watching anyway and thanks everyone else
for watching we'll leave it there
Godspeed